[Música]
no me puede pasar esto a mí no puede ser
soy una experta años estudiando este
tema les voy a contar lo que pasó este
es mi hijo benjamín tiene un año y medio
y este es mi auto nuevo voy a dejar a
benjamín en su butaca pero eso sí lo voy
a estar muy bien con doble cinturón
y ahora en el asiento de adelante voy a
dejar todo lo que llevamos las madres
con un niño de un año y medio los bolsos
las carteras los abrigos y las llaves
del auto y cierro la puerta y cuando voy
al asiento del conductor me doy cuenta
que el auto tenía cierre centralizado y
yo no sabía es decir que mi bebé se
quedó encerrado dentro del auto me
empieza a correr un frío de los pies a
la cabeza me invade el miedo la
desesperación ay qué hago qué hago qué
hago
miro a la izquierda y un cartel que dice
cerrajería vos podés creer que estás en
el auto en la puerta de la cerrajería mi
salvación
entró corriendo desesperada y le cuento
al chico lo que había pasado mi bebé se
había quedado adentro del auto
el chico hola
no no abrimos autos acá
y no abren autos claro bueno vamos
ladrillo por favor me voy a calmar
tranquilo paulista respiro mi nombre es
paulino este me especializa en el
estudio de las inteligencias en las
infancias
específicamente la detección temprana de
potencialidades pero que es una
potencialidad en el campo de las
inteligencias hay una gran diversidad
una inteligencia puede ser real la
podemos observar a través de una acción
y eso es una habilidad o puede haber una
inteligencia potencial donde está todo
para ser desarrollado pero para
descubrirla hay que saber mirar
un tipo de inteligencia es la
inteligencia emocional goleman la había
divulgado a nivel popular pero ya cinco
años antes masieri salobo ya habían
realizado aportes teóricos y de
investigación sobre este tema en líneas
generales la inteligencia emocional es
la habilidad para percibir o registrar
comunicar y valorar nuestras emociones
tanto las nuestras como las de los demás
por ejemplo el chico que me recibe la
cerrajería no está utilizando
inteligencia emocional porque no
registra no percibe que yo tengo miedo
estoy desesperada pero yo tampoco la
estoy utilizando
porque me invade el miedo y es quien
está dirigiendo mis acciones por eso
quiero romper la ventana del auto
lucas mala y si va a decir que somos
seres emocionales
es decir vamos a responder primero desde
el cerebro límbico para luego pasar a la
razón entonces las emociones son como
ese motor que van a regir nuestros
pensamientos y por tanto nuestras
acciones
ahora vos conocés mucho más de
inteligencia emocional de lo que vos
crees más habiendo atravesado una
pandemia por casi dos años juego y quién
es este extraño que está acá en mi cama
no para es mi pareja pero antes yo lo
veía dos horas al día ahora no sé quién
es
papis y mamis para mañana nuestros niños
deberán contar con un azulejo para la
clase de química
en serio me estás pidiendo un azulejo a
las 21 horas en pandemia las escuelas
tampoco supieron muy bien cómo
acomodarse a todo lo que nos estaba
pasando mandaban tareas mandaban tareas
y las familias estábamos atravesadas por
miedos angustias inseguridades
irritabilidad
ahora hay un factor común tanto para
detectar potencialidades como para
regular las emociones y esa es la forma
de mirar
pregunta hasta alguna vez cómo miras
como miras las infancias las
adolescencias la mirada es todo tanto
para descubrir potencialidad recursos
habilidades como para no mirarlas para
no reconocerlas
tuve el honor de realizar una estancia
de investigación postdoctoral con uno de
los pioneros en el estudio de las
inteligencias el doctor joseph renzulli
de la universidad de connecticut de
quien aprendí muchísimo pero tengo una
mala noticia show
el mejor curso de
detección de potencialidades y de
regulación de emociones lo recibí del
señor cerrajero ahora vamos a volver a
la escena si les cuento cómo terminó un
pueblo un ladrillo te pido espere está
bien el dueño me dice el chico el dueño
un hombre de unos 60 con un delantal
marrón hasta las rodillas manos en los
bolsillos y una sonrisa amplia a las
nueve de la mañana cómo le va buen día
que necesita me dirijo el enterrado el
ladrillo por favor no se preocupe vamos
a observar qué está pasando el buen
hombre empieza a girar alrededor del
auto
observando toda la escena con esta
tranquilidad yo atrás de separar
no veo que tenga ninguna herramienta
este buen hombre se detiene en la
ventana de mi hijo y me dice parece acá
sí jefecito como no él es el experto él
tiene la habilidad de abrir una puerta
de un auto le vamos a hacer caso
sonríe y me dice bueno
dígale cabra
o sea tiene un año y medio mi hijo
viva la cabra
bueno entre romper la ventana y probar
lo que dice el experto
mi hija venga
hola benjamín ando y descubriendo el
mundo como desde pequeña me en hama más
hola soy la hija como el las levántate y
abril abril abril la manija tira
mi hija se incorpora logra salir de los
dos cinturones
estira su manito de un año y medio
abre la puerta
señor me vuelve el alma al cuerpo
gracias gracias gracias gracias que le
debo
y el hombre me dice a mí
usted a mí no me debe nada
usted lo que debe hacer es creer más en
los niños y en las niñas
y vos como miras como miras a tus hijos
a tus hijas a tus nietos a tus
compañeros de trabajo a tu pareja a vos
mismo webos misma desde el potencial
desde los recursos desde lo que funciona
o desde el problema desde lo que falta
desde lo que no
que necesita el futuro de nosotros
seres empáticos sensibles constructivos
colaborativos que sepan y puedan
gestionar sus emociones
pero por sobre todas las cosas que
puedan mirar de una manera diferente
finalmente los mejores lentes son los
ojos del alma muchas gracias